[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spring in carson palmer um
help me understand this most of these
guys get in a spread offense when
they're in junior high high school
college and not normally under center
how big a deal is this that a
quarterback
they're not comfortable running a
quarterback sneak
well i i just think all of this is
getting misconstrued a bit
um dan have you ever seen the movie heat
the al pacino movie the heat yeah i
think
i think urban's got the heat on him
right now
and everything he says is going to be
calculated and
uh maybe misconstrued a bit i just think
his point was look we haven't we haven't
run it in a game yet i didn't i wasn't
comfortable with the call on fourth and
one i'd be more comfortable if we'd run
it a couple times but i don't think in
any way he was saying trevor trevor is
not tough enough
uh he's scared of running it i don't
think that was his point and i think
that's what trevor was saying is look
you know i
i'm ready for it we haven't practiced it
and i haven't run it in the game a bunch
but at the end of the day urban's got
the heat on him and everything he says
right now is going to be
you know over thought and and talked
about by everybody i i don't think
there's anything really to this i
understand it but here's tom brady who's
still running a quarterback sneak at age
44. why can't i have a six six 23 year
old run a quarterback sneak like
is it just getting under center like why
haven't they practiced this though
that's what that quarterback sneak is
really important to a lot of
quarterbacks
unfortunately you can't practice it just
like you can't practice with the
quarterback being live in the pocket
with the starting defense breathing down
his neck lighten them up in practice
you're just not going to expose your
quarterback to injury practicing a
quarterback sneak in the game at the end
of the day they need to be in the first
quarter on third and a half a yard or
third and one and run it a couple times
to where they're able and comfortable
enough running it on fourth and one with
the game on the line but you cannot
practice it you just i i don't i've
never practiced it in in my career i've
never seen it practiced in my career
it's just something you've got a call
and a game and that's your practice
what is it like though when you go and
i'm just trying to envision this when
brady goes to the line and and we know
he's going to get the ball in the
quarterback sneak but
as far as tapping you know your centers
rear end on the right or left if you're
going to go or how that works with the
unspoken communication
yeah as you come up to line of scrimmage
you're looking for a double team meaning
your center and guard on one defensive
football player so wherever that nose
guard is the guy that's closest the
defender closest to the center lines up
if he's on the the left shoulder or the
right shoulder you just tap him on the
butt and let that guard on that side
also know that hey i want you two to
double team that guy and i'm gonna just
ride the wave i'm gonna get on the top
of your back push and we're actually
going to triple team that individual
player so it's like i said it's just
something that they actually need to
practice it in a game that's the only
opportunity they're going to have to
practice it i was just surprised that
urban didn't shake it off better
i know but belichick would have you know
defused that he would have pushed that
to the side and moved on because you
know in college you wouldn't get to talk
to the quarterback in the pros
trevor probably didn't know what urban
said he's coming in next and of course
they're going to ask him about that i i
don't know it just felt like it was a
rookie mistake from for the head coach
that's exactly what it was i mean
urban's got the heat on him everything
he says is going to be analyzed over
scrutinized and he doesn't have
he hasn't built up the equity uh that
belichick has he doesn't he hasn't
earned the right to just kind of brush
off a simple question by somebody and
move on to the next one he he's got the
heat on him every question is going to
be over analyzed and and you're right
that was a rookie mistake the way he
handled that all in on the chargers
i'm all in on the chargers because they
can rush the passer and they got one of
the best young qbs in the league i mean
that that combination um
big physical hard to cover receivers
keenan allen is still one of the best
kept secrets in the league i still don't
understand why he doesn't quite get the
love that some of these other guys do in
the league he's been doing it for a long
time at a very high level but they can
rush the password pass her with boza and
they can they can throw the ball on
anybody i mean justin herbert everybody
knows it he's a star he's a star in the
making um so i'm all in on the chargers
absolutely okay but what do you see with
justin herbert because jimmy johnson on
fox's pregame show said he would take
justin herbert over patrick mahomes
that may be a stretch i mean justin
herbert hasn't done it uh as many times
as as patrick has but i'm not saying
that i don't know that that justin
herbert has
the ability to win a super bowl or
the talent to win a super bowl we're
about to find out this season
but man the ball comes out of his hands
so effortlessly there's so much zip and
acceleration on the football coming off
of his fingertips and he can take off
and run i mean you saw him you saw him
use his legs he is a complete threat run
it throw it he's smart he's actually
does a really really good job for a
young quarterback too he does not panic
there's a lot of times where he held on
the ball for a little bit too late and
then you see that quarterback that's
young that tries to throw it away at the
end and a guy tips it and it becomes a
pick or it becomes a fumble he's really
really calm in bad situations and knows
when to just eat it and live for another
play and take the sack and move on to
second and 16. so
um i just really like the temperament
that he's playing with right now
what would concern you about the chiefs
just defense i mean they're obviously
built with speed on the back end if you
look at the back end of that defense
there's not a defender over 210 pounds
they're built to stop the past
you know you get in situations against
them late in the season especially and
with the weather last night
the wind the rain
you got to be able to run the ball you
know forcefully down people's throats
and
that's the one thing that kansas city
can't really stop right now is you you
can attack them in the run game they are
built to stop the pass because they're
really building around patrick obviously
and you know they want to be in a
situation where they're up 28 17 or 35
21 where they they force the opposing
offense into a throwing game
but last night you saw them get exposed
i mean they hung 38 points on them last
night
patrick isn't going to be able to keep
up with every single opposing offense
every week there's going to be games
like that
but i'm i'm in saying all that i don't
think that um
i'm not saying that the chiefs aren't
going to make a run at it i think
they're going to be deep you know deep
in the playoffs at the end of this
season but that's definitely a concern
is the amount of points that have been
hung on early on this year
i've had this philosophy with the chiefs
but tell me how
and maybe it's it sounds simplistic and
it's not
but i would have my defense my backs
play deep like i would never let tyrek
hill beat me i want everything in front
of me you want to get 10 yarders 15
yarders fine we're going to take
advantage of your defense when you're on
the field they like to strike quick and
i want to know if they have the patience
to be able to do something like that and
that is
no home runs you want to hit doubles hit
doubles uh and make them value every
possession they have that they have to
score because your defense isn't that
good is that too simplistic going
against the chiefs
well i i think the issue with playing
them like that is travis kelsey if
travis kelsey's injured and he isn't
available to work the underneath routes
and around you know between the hashes
10 yards or or shallower you know you
can sit back and play them but but
travis is going to eat you alive if
you're just going to sit back and try to
stop the deep ball the big issue is
travis and then the x factor outside of
all that is andy reid he's always going
to have something really
with a motion with a shift some sort of
quick screen he's always going to do
something to keep you on your toes as a
defensive coordinator so the combination
of
travis kelsey working the underneath
coverage in the middle of the field and
then you got the you got big red call in
place from the sideline i just don't
think you can sit back uh and make them
be patient because they can still get
you with kelsey what do you think of
trayvon diggs for defensive player of
the year
oh i mean if the season stopped right
now there's not a doubt about it um he'd
win it i mean he just he just
continuously finds ways to get the ball
and the other thing about him is a lot
there's a lot of dbs that you see and
watch that they're gonna drop a handful
of picks you know they they may end up
going to the pro bowl with seven eight
nine picks but they could have had 13 if
they would have caught them all that's
the thing about trayvon the ball doesn't
hit the ground if he's got an
opportunity to catch it he makes the
play he completes the interception he is
like a receiver out there at defensive
back
but
did you uh how often would you avoid a
defensive back in your career
it depends on who it was i mean if it
was somebody like rebus
yeah revis could shut down half the
field and
um
he was kind of similar to trey long when
the ball was in the air rebus was going
to catch it there was very few balls
that just bounced off of his fingertips
he had receiver-like hands but if you
got a revis
or i played a bunch against troy
palamalu and ed reed and
if it was troy we ran the ball away from
him if he rotated down to the left side
of the field we ran the ball to right
vice versa if it was ed and ed was
double teaming a player or taking away a
half of the field i would just work the
other side of the field so
trayvon's that type of player if
trayvon's lined up on your number one
regardless of who it is you should be
thinking of working the other side of
the field no doubt jack prescott talked
about he had to move past this game he
got injured you know with his ankle but
uh and and drew brees talked about this
too that you can't help but think about
that injury
how often would you how long did it take
you to move past when you got hurt
against the steelers
you know it just takes getting past that
next game because unfortunately for dak
and you heard him say it after the game
he said i'm just glad this game is over
with i'm just glad i can get past it and
that's not a mental hurdle for him that
he can't get over it's just he's been
asked about it week after week after
week and his teammates have been asked
about it week after week so it's just
something that you when it's constantly
being asked of you you may not be
necessarily you know have a hurdle in
your mind that you can't get past it but
when somebody's constantly reminding you
the new york giants last year you're
playing the new york giants in three
weeks and two weeks and one week it just
naturally comes up in your head so i you
know i think that can can put this
behind him they're sitting at i believe
four and one right now one of the best
offenses in the league he's proven that
he can take a hit he can take off and
run he can step into throws he's gotten
that injury behind him and i just expect
him to continue to flourish as the
season progresses what's your philosophy
on quarterbacks trying to make tackles
on interceptions
given what happened to baker mayfield
you got to try
there's no doubt about it i mean when
you make a mistake and you put the ball
in the wrong place or you didn't throw
it on time and everybody else did their
job correctly there's an awful feeling
as a quarterback when you throw that
thing and it's starting to head in a
different direction and then you got
your defense on the sideline that maybe
is playing a great game
and they don't want that stack going on
their side of the stat line because
those interceptions that end up being
touchdowns those end up counting as
points against your defense so every
quarterback knows that every quarterback
thinks about that you don't have to make
the tackle you just got to make sure he
doesn't get in the end zone but you have
to give effort you have to try or else
you're going to hear it from every
teammate yeah but you know when i see
tom brady go in a fetal position when
he's going to be sacked or peyton
manning
kind of
tries a little bit but he doesn't want
to touch that person who just picked him
off like those are guys that survived 20
years you know these guys who want to
make the like baker may feel you know
you want to stick somebody now he's got
you know a damaged shoulder
yeah baker mayfield's not peyton manning
and baker mayfield is not tom brady
those guys have earned the right to make
sure they stay healthy
i think baker's three four five years
and a number of statistics away from
being able to to be able to take kind of
a hall pass on having to make a tackle
how many tackles do you think you made
in your career
i had a couple good ones um i missed i
certainly missed more than i made but i
i had a big chip on my shoulder if i
threw a pick and it was going the
opposite direction i wasn't worried
about injury i was worried about my
teammates and letting them down so i was
given everything i had i was a terrible
tackler and now that i'm coaching
football and i actually coach a lot of
the defensive stuff so i'm trying to
talk about tackling and technique and
form and i can talk a good game but as
far as actually being able to execute it
fundamentally and technically i can't
tell you paulie how many tackles did
carson have in his nfl career oh i'll
i'll get the good stuff first 294
touchdown passes okay that's a lot of
touchdowns okay
i got one tackle
see i could tackle it as a rookie
oh it came as a rookie
yeah yeah i know you gotta prove
yourself once right
do you put you think you put the fear
you know of just in that defense thing
if i pick him off and last thing i want
is carson palmer to hit me
i don't know i threw a pic in pittsburgh
to troy palamalu
my i think it was early on in my career
and he was my old roommate from college
and i don't know where he came from i
thought i had a nice easy completion and
all of a sudden i see this giant paw go
up in one hand this catch
and i kind of i got knocked down i
turned around and i was standing on my
own goal line and by the time i looked
up troy was coming at me full speed and
all i could do was duck my head and put
my arms up and he ran me over he put his
he actually i still have a pain in my
shoulder he put his helmet right in my
ac joint on my shoulder and ran me over
for a pick six
and i think that was the one tackle
oh wait you get credit for that
i got him on the ground
in the end zone in the end but he went
to the ground
does he say anything to you after a play
like that
no troy never says anything to anybody
so if it was anybody else they would
probably be talking trash
but troy never i never heard troy talk
any trash in the field if there's any
football player that ever had the right
to talk trash it was probably troy and
you hear that voice
and if i say
that like mike tyson where you go
that's the baddest man on the planet or
that's a hall of fame defensive like i
would never think troy palamalu was
one of those i'm all over the like a
yoga instructor troy troy is like my
sensei or something
yeah just a sweetheart off the field but
once once guys like him or mike tyson
get in the ring they become pit bulls
and you got to watch out
but you know you get these guys you
can't be both right like you can't be
crazy off the field and on the field can
you
uh yeah i believe you can
i played with a number of those oh you
did
yeah you got any names
uh
ocho ocho was crazy off the field
like how crazy on the field how crazy
was chad johnson off the field
i mean it depends on your definition of
crazy but um
i remember when twitter first came out
chad and nobody really knew what twitter
was but chad was definitely on it and
chad would go to the local mall in
cincinnati
and send out a tweet saying hey i'm
standing outside of
dick's sporting goods
and sure enough
400 people show up and want to hang out
and then he'd take them all in and buy
everybody a pair of shoes or
you know do something i i guess that's
not crazy that's that's awesome but um
he was just as crazy on the field as he
was off i mean just as far as doing
something you wouldn't expect i wouldn't
expect him to try to deplete ray lewis
on the field but he
tried heinz ward said that the steelers
were afraid of james harrison
i believe it i believe i actually i
remember playing again in a game against
james harrison and uh
somebody got in a little bit of an
altercation kind of after a play
somebody was there was a little bit of a
scruffle and i'll never forget tashay
townsend came in he was a
in the secondary he came in out of the
secondary and the shea with the shea was
giving the bengals our team a friendly
warning like
you do not want any of that back up
right now
and it was out of like fear that one of
us was gonna get broken or snapped
and chances are it'd be you
no doubt i was yeah i was in james
crosshairs all the times
hey it's great to talk to you again
thanks as always and uh we look forward
to next week
thank you that's carson palmer his
weekly appearance in the nfl season
brought to you by our partner level
select cbd